why do your members want to go on strike
well they don't want to go on strike
they feel that they've been put into a
position where
that is of course we have to take
because the companies are planning
thousands of job cuts which we believe
threatens the safety regimes on our
railway
they are seeking to dilute and transform
our working conditions and working
practices
and we haven't had a pay rise now going
into the third year the third
anniversary
so they're feeling that cost of living
crisis like every other worker in this
country
and it's our job to get them a deal from
the companies that we just think they
can afford and we think our members
deserve having kept the railway system
going
during the past two years when they all
had of course had to
work on the front line delivering those
services
uh we're hearing from the government
this morning on this program considering
legislating to ensure minimum staffing
levels in the event of a strike
when i put that to the minister he said
he wasn't ruling anything out and it was
certainly in the conservative manifesto
well the conservatives have got a habit
of suppressing civil liberties and the
right to resist
we've got the uh
public order bill going through which
seeks to to clamp down the right to
protest even it's a civil liberty and a
democratic right to withdraw your labor
in this country it's established going
back
to the toll paddle mars and the charters
and through the suffrage movement and
the trade union movement over the last
200 years
we will maintain that and fight to fight
for our right to withdraw our action and
act independently of the government they
want a cowed trade union movement
because they want to
preserve big profits through driving
down wages and conditions of workers
right across our economy
what about those uh workers who are
commuters who are desperate to get to
work they can't afford to drive because
of fuel costs at the moment and
businesses
in in major cities that rely on uh
trains to bring people into those cities
well we want all of those uh businesses
to prosper we want commuters to get a
fair deal off the railway because
they're being ripped off as well last
year
the railway companies took out at least
500 million pound of profit from the
railway and that was in a time where
fares were low and passenger usage was
low because of the coveted lockdowns and
the instructions to work from home and
so on so people are making vast and
exorbitant profits the chief executives
and the directors of railway companies
are on enormous salaries in this country
hundreds of thousands of pounds up to
half a million pounds per year
so there isn't enough money in the in
the railway industry to pay
for our members to have a reasonable pay
deal and indeed to have a low-level
affairs and countries right across
europe in ireland france and germany are
actually cutting their fares to bring
back the travelership so that the
service into the cities and to our towns
and villages can be restored and so the
economy can prosper we want to be part
of that but of course railway workers
need to be there to ensure a safe and
comfortable service and to ensure that
passengers get the right assistance but
we need to be paid properly as well
24-hour walkouts on the london
underground as well tfl say that you are
trying to spoil and disrupt the jubilee
weekend are you
no i mean there's a strike that's coming
up uh amongst station staff that's not
over the jubilee weekend and this
dispute that we're talking about now on
the national railway will not be over
the jubilee weekend there's a small
dispute a cluster of stations in central
london which is less than 80 of our
members we're seeking to resolve that
dispute this week and hopefully we can
do that if the company comes out of a
reasonable position
so you're suggesting that that strike
that is i think the day after the
jubilee weekend jubilee weekend
celebrations uh that might not go ahead
well that one may go ahead because
there is not an agreement they're
looking to slash 600 jobs and again rip
up our conditions of our members they're
also looking to clamp down the pensions
and remove the value of that so
there are 4 000 people involved in that
dispute on on the monday after the
holiday but that won't interfere with
those celebrations uh that dispute is
not planned for that period
good to talk to you thanks for joining
us on the program